l'intrication quantique permet aux particules d'être liées peu importe l'espace entre elles, c'est tellement contre-intuitif
que même Einstein ne pensait pas que c'était vrai dans l'épisode d'aujourd'hui de Qiskit in the Classroom on va parler de comment le théorème de Bell a prouvé qu'Einstein
avait tort
bienvenue dans Qiskit in the Classroom dans cette série on va utiliser Qiskit pour explorer quelques concepts fondamentaux souvent
abordés dans les cours liés à l'informatique quantique chaque vidéo sera aussi accompagnée d'un module interactif
lié dans la description ci-dessous alors n'hésite pas à le consulter dans la vidéo sur les pièces de monnaie quantiques on a discuté de comment mesurer une
superposition quantique est un processus intrinsèquement probabiliste comme lancer une pièce à certains égards mais comment sait-on
ça pourrait-il être qu'une particule quantique cache secrètement un résultat prédéterminé d'une mesure mais qu'on n'arrive d'une façon ou d'une autre pas à
capturer cette information dans notre théorie dans les premiers temps de la mécanique quantique cette question faisait l'objet
d'un débat enflammé avec deux factions principales dans un camp il y avait Einstein qui croyait que la mécanique quantique était incomplète
c'est-à-dire qu'il lui manquait certaines variables qui étaient nécessaires pour décrire entièrement un système Einstein pensait que
ces soi-disant variables cachées si trouvées résoudraient certains des aspects apparemment paradoxaux et probabilistes
de la mécanique quantique dans l'autre camp il y avait Max Born Born soutenait
que la description probabiliste donnée par la mécanique quantique est tout ce qui est spécifié par la nature en d'autres termes ce
n'est pas juste qu'on ne connaît pas l'état d'une particule avant de la mesurer c'est que la particule n'a pas d'état défini
avant d'être mesurée pendant des décennies beaucoup pensaient que ce désaccord était une question philosophique qui ne serait peut-être jamais
résolue après tout pour apprendre quoi que ce soit sur un système il faut le mesurer comment peut-on jamais apprendre
quoi que ce soit sur la nature d'un état avant sa mesure puis en 1964 le physicien
John Bell a trouvé un moyen dans son article Bell a examiné les corrélations statistiques entre les mesures d'une paire de
particules intriquées si avant la mesure les états des particules étaient déterminés par certaines variables cachées inconnues
alors Bell a trouvé que leurs corrélations avaient une limite supérieure d'un autre côté quand il a calculé les
corrélations prédites par la mécanique quantique il a trouvé qu'elles violaient cette limite donc il avait trouvé un moyen de une fois pour toutes
différencier entre les points de vue d'Einstein et de Born il ne restait plus qu'à tester expérimentalement
ces corrélations avec de vraies particules pour voir si elles obéissaient aux statistiques des variables cachées ou si elles
violaient cette règle ces tests ont été effectués avec une précision et une sophistication croissantes
au fil des années et ce sont certaines des expériences les plus significatives de la physique moderne ils étaient tellement révolutionnaires que
ils ont valu à trois physiciens le prix Nobel en 2022 mais de nos jours n'importe qui peut effectuer un
test de Bell tout ce dont tu as besoin c'est un peu de connaissance de Qiskit et d'un accès à un ordinateur quantique IBM dans cette vidéo je vais
te guider à travers la logique de l'inégalité de Bell puis je te montrerai comment on peut tester les prédictions de Bell sur un ordinateur quantique IBM
l'inégalité de Bell implique plusieurs mesures différentes et des couches de logique et ça peut être
un peu difficile à suivre mais on va le parcourir étape par étape et à la fin ça en vaudra la peine on est sur le point de montrer
que l'intrication est réelle et qu'Einstein a tort ce n'est pas quelque chose que beaucoup de gens peuvent dire avoir fait alors voici
ce que Bell a proposé disons que tu as un moyen de produire beaucoup de copies d'une paire de particules intriquées physiquement
ces paires pourraient être produites par un processus de désintégration où une particule se désintègre en deux si tu as regardé la vidéo sur l'
expérience de Stern-Gerlach tu sais que les particules peuvent avoir un moment cinétique intrinsèque appelé
spin disons qu'une particule de spin zéro se désintègre en deux particules de spin 1/2
alors chacune des particules de spin 1/2 peut être mesurée pour avoir soit un spin plus 1/2 soit moins
1/2 aussi appelé spin haut ou spin bas mais puisqu'elles se sont désintégrées depuis une particule de spin zéro les deux doivent se combiner pour
avoir un spin total de zéro également donc si l'une est mesurée comme étant haut l'autre doit être
bas et vice versa ces particules forment une paire intriquée qui ressemble à ça
donc si l'une est mesurée comme étant haut l'autre est bas et vice versa disons que la particule un part vers la gauche ou
dans la direction moins X où un chercheur qu'on appellera Lucas mesure son
spin puis la particule deux part pareillement vers la droite
où une autre chercheuse Rihanna peut mesurer ce spin Lucas et Rihanna peuvent indépendamment
faire tourner leurs appareils de mesure pour choisir de mesurer le spin de leurs particules respectives selon n'importe quelle direction
perpendiculaire à la direction de mouvement de la particule si on envoie beaucoup de copies de l'état intriqué à Lucas
et Rihanna ils peuvent collecter des statistiques de mesure s'ils mesurent toujours selon le même axe ces statistiques ne seront pas
très intéressantes à chaque fois que l'un mesure spin haut l'autre mesure spin bas et à chaque fois que l'un mesure spin
en avant l'autre mesure spin en arrière et ainsi de suite mais si les deux chercheurs mesurent selon des axes différents on pourrait trouver
quelque chose de plus intéressant donnons à Lucas et Rihanna trois axes selon lesquels
mesurer on appellera ces axes a b et c et ils sont chacun séparés de
120° la question qu'on va poser avec cette expérience est si Lucas et Rihanna sont libres de mesurer selon l'un des trois
axes quelle sera la fréquence à laquelle les deux obtiendront le même signe clairement si Lucas et Rihanna mesurent par hasard selon le même axe
disons l'axe a ils ne peuvent jamais obtenir le même signe puisque les particules doivent se combiner pour avoir un spin zéro mais quand ils choisissent
des axes différents comment leurs mesures seront-elles corrélées si tant est qu'elles le soient selon Einstein cette description
mécano-quantique de l'état des particules est incomplète il pensait qu'il devait exister des variables cachées qui
prédéterminent le résultat de toutes les mesures de spin possible parce que sans ça les particules intriquées devraient
d'une façon ou d'une autre communiquer le résultat de leur mesure instantanément si l'une était mesurée comme étant
haut là-bas l'autre devrait instantanément savoir être bas ici
ces variables cachées pourraient être n'importe quel ensemble compliqué d'instructions pour le résultat des expériences mais l'important est
que l'état de spin de chaque particule séparément est déterminé donc aucune communication n'est nécessaire
expérimentalement ça signifierait que les mesures faites par Lucas n'auraient aucun effet sur la particule de Rihanna et vice
versa ça pourrait imposer certaines limites sur le degré de corrélation des deux mesures selon Born cependant cet état
psi est tout ce qu'on peut dire sur la paire de particules avant la mesure donc la mesure d'une particule
affecte le résultat de la mesure de l'autre ceci peut avoir des implications différentes pour les corrélations entre les mesures voyons comment chaque
théorie affecte ces corrélations dans le traitement des variables cachées il y a un ensemble secret d'instructions avant
la mesure qui détermine déjà ce que Lucas va mesurer selon chacun des trois axes par exemple ces
instructions pourraient être positives si Lucas mesure selon un axe a
positives s'il mesure selon B et négatives s'il mesure selon c on peut
écrire ça comme plus a plus b et moins C alors la particule de Rihanna
devrait avoir les variables moins a moins B et plus C pour s'assurer que le spin total
selon n'importe quelle direction unique est zéro
il y a huit ensembles d'instructions possibles qui satisfont cette contrainte de spin zéro donc chaque fois qu'une nouvelle paire de
particules est envoyée à Lucas et Rihanna elle pourrait contenir l'un de ces huit ensembles d'instructions alors maintenant on veut
déterminer en supposant que les particules contiennent l'un des ensembles secrets d'instructions donnés dans le tableau et
en supposant que Lucas et Rihanna choisissent chacun indépendamment lequel des trois axes mesurer quelle est la
probabilité qu'ils mesurent tous les deux le même signe si les instructions sont celles données dans les lignes 1 ou
8 alors clairement cette probabilité est zéro puisque les deux particules auront les signes opposés peu importe leurs
axes de mesure mais qu'en est-il des instructions dans la ligne deux ils mesureraient les mêmes signes si
Rihanna mesurait selon c et Lucas mesurait selon soit a soit b ou si Lucas
mesurait selon c et Rihanna mesurait selon soit A soit B donc ça fait quatre sur neuf des
combinaisons de mesures possibles qui donneront à Lucas et Rihanna le même signe si on fait ça pour
chaque ensemble d'instructions tu verras que les lignes 3 à 7 donnent aussi une probabilité de 4/9 ça signifie que si
Einstein a raison et que des variables cachées comme celles-là prédéterminent le résultat des mesures il n'y a aucun moyen pour Lucas
et Rihanna de jamais mesurer le même signe avec une probabilité supérieure à 4/9 c'est l'inégalité de Bell P inférieur ou
égal à 4/9 et comme on va le montrer les particules intriquées violent ça alors pour
voir ce que prédit la mécanique quantique disons que Lucas mesure selon a deux choses peuvent se passer soit il mesure spin haut donc
Rihanna mesurerait spin bas selon a soit il mesure spin bas et Rihanna mesurerait spin haut selon a mais on
veut la probabilité que Rihanna mesure le même signe que Lucas selon n'importe quel axe de son choix pas seulement a si
elle mesure selon soit B soit C ça devient un peu compliqué il s'avère que
si tu sais ce que Rihanna va mesurer avec 100% de certitude selon une direction alors tu peux calculer les probabilités
qu'elle mesure haut ou bas selon n'importe quel autre axe avec un peu de géométrie
si ton état mesure toujours spin haut selon un axe alors la probabilité de mesurer spin haut selon un axe différent
sera égale au carré du cosinus de la moitié de l'angle entre les deux axes c'est un peu compliqué mais
je vais te montrer ce que je veux dire si Lucas mesure spin haut selon a on sait avec 100% de certitude que Rihanna mesurerait
spin bas si elle devait mesurer a donc on peut représenter ça avec un vecteur
comme ça dans ce cas les angles entre ce vecteur et les deux autres axes de mesure B et C sont tous les deux
de 60° donc la moitié de ça est 30° et le cosinus de
30 est montré ici cosinus carré de
30° est égal à 3/4 maintenant si Lucas mesure spin bas
selon a on sait que Rihanna mesurerait spin haut selon a donc on peut dessiner un autre vecteur ici maintenant
ce vecteur représentant cette connaissance est à 120° de chacun des deux autres axes B
et C donc on peut faire le même truc de géométrie mais cette fois on aura le cosinus de
60° donc cosinus carré de
60° est égal à 1/4 puisque Lucas a une probabilité égale de
mesurer spin haut et spin bas selon a on doit faire la moyenne de ces deux probabilités de Rihanna on obtient une probabilité finale
que Rihanna mesure le même signe que Lucas de 1/2 donc P
égal 1/2 est plus grand que 4/9 donc l'inégalité de Bell est violée
ça signifie que tant que les règles de la mécanique quantique tiennent les variables cachées sont impossibles maintenant on peut utiliser Qiskit et un
ordinateur quantique IBM pour tester l'inégalité de Bell avec de vraies mesures quantiques on peut associer les états spin haut et
spin bas des particules de Lucas et Rihanna aux états zéro et un des qubits dans l'ordinateur quantique on va
prendre deux qubits un pour représenter la particule de Lucas et un pour celle de Rihanna et les intriquer avec ce circuit quantique
donc les deux qubits sont représentés par les deux fils q0 et q1 et cette combinaison
de gates X Hadamard et C-NOT créera le même état intriqué qu'on avait entre les particules de Lucas et Rihanna maintenant on
doit mesurer chaque qubit on va définir la mesure de Lucas selon a ce qu'on dira être l'axe Z puis la mesure de Rihanna
peut être selon a b ou c donc on aura besoin de trois circuits séparés pour chacun de ces trois cas mais dans cette
vidéo on va juste en faire un tu peux aller au module lié dans la description pour la version complète si Rihanna mesure selon
B alors notre circuit ressemble à ça où r y est une rotation de 120 degrés pour changer
l'axe de mesure de Rihanna on peut utiliser le sampler primitif de Qiskit pour faire tourner cette expérience plusieurs fois et collecter
des statistiques à partir des mesures résultantes les deux colonnes 0 0 et 1 1 représentent les fois où Lucas et
Rihanna ont mesuré le même signe ce qui est ce qu'on cherche donc la probabilité de mesurer les deux particules avec le même
signe est très proche de 1/2 ça viole l'inégalité de Bell ça signifie
que les deux particules sont intriquées chacune semble d'une façon ou d'une autre savoir instantanément les résultats d'une
mesure de l'autre il y a encore un certain désaccord sur comment exactement interpréter cette
intrication et ce qui se passe quand tu mesures un état intriqué mais ces questions sont plutôt philosophiques la
théorie est assez indéniable à ce stade l'intrication est définitivement réelle et on le sait grâce à Bell son
inégalité et aux nombreux physiciens qui ont effectué des expériences pour la tester si tu veux être compté parmi ces
physiciens et effectuer ton propre test de Bell avec un ordinateur quantique n'hésite pas à te rendre au module sur l'inégalité de Bell
lié dans la description merci d'avoir regardé et à la prochaine